[Música]
noticias de la economía con Juan Pablo
lucumí Juan Pablo hacemos el repaso y
acá estamos otra vez Ángela Qué ha
pasado Juan Pablo con las negociaciones
sobre el techo de la deuda en Estados
Unidos vamos a verlo Ángela porque el
acuerdo especificaría la cantidad Total
que el gobierno podría gastar en
programas direccionados a pues como la
vivienda y la educación aunque no
desglosaría en categorías individuales
según una fuente de Washington la falta
de acuerdos que lleva meses mantienen
nerviosos a los inversionistas afectando
las acciones estadounidenses y
encareciendo el costo del endeudamiento
del país el presidente Joe biden afirmó
que evitará el impago mientras avanza la
carrera por encontrar un acuerdo entre
la casa blanca y los negociadores
republicanos sobre este asunto
escuchemos macartillo hemos tenido
varias conversaciones productivas y de
hecho nuestro personal continúa
reuniéndose mientras hablamos y están
progresando dejé en claro una y otra vez
que el incumplimiento de pago de nuestra
deuda nacional no es una opción el
pueblo estadounidense merece saber que
los pagos del seguro social estarán allí
que el hospital de veteranos permanecerá
abierto y que se logrará un progreso
económico y lo Seguiremos logrando el
default pone todo eso en riesgo los
líderes del Congreso entienden eso y
todos han acordado que no habrá
incumplimiento es hora de que el
congreso actúe ahora Simplemente nos
queda la expectativa de saber si hoy se
dará o no se dará un acuerdo no Usted
sabe que el fin de semana se empiezan a
desactivar un poco las cosas y eso
preocupa Así es Ángela vamos a pasar a
América Latina Argentina la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández
criticó una vez más el acuerdo que el
país tiene con el fmi Esa es la noticia
ya lo escucharemos específicamente pero
recordemos que Argentina gran productor
sudamericano de granos tiene una
historia tensa con el fondo monetario
internacional en 2018 Argentina acordó
un programa de 57 mil millones de
dólares con el organismo bajo el mandato
del líder conservador Mauricio macri
esto con el objetivo de evitar una
crisis económica
ese acuerdo fracasó y fue reemplazado el
año pasado con un acuerdo para
refinanciar los 44 mil millones de
dólares en deuda pendiente escuchemos lo
que dijo la vicepresidenta de este
jueves
si nosotros los argentinos y las
argentinas
no logramos
que ese programa que el fondo monetario
impone a todos sus deudores
se ha dejado de lado
y nos permita elaborar un programa
propio de crecimiento
de industrialización
de innovación tecnológica
va a ser imposible pagarlo Por más que
digan lo que digan
sin embargo momentos Así es en los que
uno esperaría que hubiera una propuesta
política al respecto lo cual estuvo
completamente ausente de este evento
multitudinario de la vicepresidenta Así
es Ángela y pese a las críticas de la
vicepresidenta este acuerdo que llega
antes de las elecciones presidenciales
pues ella ha hecho que no será candidata
de los comicios y el actual presidente
Alberto Fernández quien en su mandato
pues la inflación superó las tres cifras
hasta llegar al 108,8% anual en abril
tampoco se presentará entonces habrá que
ver quién serán los reemplazados bien
vamos a pasar muy rápidamente a noticias
del continente africano Juan Pablo
pasamos a África para hablar de la
inflación y el juego del Banco Central
por intentar contenerla Pues este jueves
el banco de Sudáfrica elevó los tipos de
referencia en 50 puntos básicos hasta el
8,25% lo que supone un máximo de 14 años
y lo que muestra la ambición del
encargado de controlar la política
monetaria de tratar de reducir la
inflación Y eso que en abril estuvo en
el 6,8% y venía el 7,8 y 7,5 y para el
cierre los indicadores empezamos
entonces con Estados Unidos porque el
índice de precios de gasto de consumo
personal en abril se aceleró a 4,4%
anualizado este es uno de los
principales datos que tiene en cuenta la
reserva Federal para tomar sus
decisiones respecto al aumento de tasas
con esto Pues los tres indicadores de
Wall Street abrieron en positivo en
América Latina la mayoría de plazas
volvieron a retroceder al cierre de la
jornada pero el principal indicador de
Colombia fue el que nuevamente lideró la
caída pero también tuvo pérdidas Brasil
y México tuvieron ganancias y el índice
merval de Argentina no cotizó por ser
día feriado en ese país las bolsas
europeas siguen operando en su mayoría
con ganancias no siendo más Juan Pablo
Le deseo que tenga un feliz fin de
semana y nos vemos después con más
información nosotros nos vamos en
directo a París